hatred the video game is that next week
on Steam it's not coming out on gog.com
they won't have it on a bunch of
websites and article especially the
mainstream press in recent weeks have
been getting in a kerfuffle about this
game which basically involves you
murdering a hell a bunch of civilians
civilians man violence in video games
have we gone too far
Justin you're obviously keeping your
finger on the post newswise what do you
think about the kerfuffle that's
surrounded hatred well so the problem
isn't that you're killing civilians we
kill civilians and tons of games great
Otto is about I mean is not about
killing civilians it's more how
incredibly realistic how for me like I
had a very negative reaction to watching
the trailers you're not just kind of
mindlessly bullying over people who are
mannequins and we're just like joke
characters you're shooting people in the
face who are fighting again who are
saying no who want to hold on to their
lives and it makes it kind of terrible
you're just like I'm gonna go in a robe
like why are you doing it because I'm
crazy gotta go kill people who are
crying and you're gonna shoot them in
the face like so you're saying you're
saying it as if it's [ __ ] up and mad
kind of Sansa larious to me in a weird
way laughing yeah I'm kind of laughing
it does sound like it might be to like I
can definitely see how somebody showing
this footage unlike CNN Oh piss people
off it's quite BAE that way but do you
think it's do you think like this sort
of violence is too much in the wake of
like you growing up like were there
games that you thought were too much
because like we go back and think what
the fun and games back in the day where
you think Carmageddon soldier fortune
postal - yeah soldier fortune moments
great you could shoot off the limbs with
a shotgun definitely playing that when I
was like 14 or younger maybe so but I
will say this when I see Mortal Kombat X
right and I think about like a kid
playing that today that's like way
different than when we were playing
Mortal Kombat my mom was like hey that's
pretty gross like you should you made
you clay fighter and said yeah well I'm
somebody and then added three gallons of
blood flow out but it's like oh it's so
very pixelated incredibly fake but in
man when it's like kind of detailed in
the animations are all good and there's
a great sound design it's like whoa man
as a kid like I guess it's not that much
different cuz it's still cartoons that's
that's the thing I like is it's cartoony
but it makes it real like when you rip
off somebody's skull it's like oh that
looks like the inside of a skull and
brains and that's that I feel really
worried about this because like whenever
we get into this area of all we
shouldn't accept that or like we should
hold games up to a higher standard like
it it will put people say that it like
it sends like what like [ __ ] in the
mainstream media used to say about games
like GTA we're like you just you just
you know understand and when we play
these games it's not like it's really
not real like look at this this is
basically a high-res version of postal 1
like this looks like postal it's an
isometric shooter where it barely has
any color in it and it's you know you're
just mowing down a bunch of people like
this look that bad like I think the
gameplay is fine it's it's more what
I've seen in the trailers that may
hatred less palatable less it doesn't
seem like fun like I'm gonna I'm in a
playground of kind of ridiculous
destruction for me that's never been a
pull like I don't go in a moral comment
like oh I can't wait to see these
eviscerations they all this gross stuff
but it wasn't my idea made like I don't
know you're all for that's why I've been
mortal combat I don't play delia
fighting and I don't play Mortal Kombat
I don't it doesn't look yes guy right in
his eye right it's better like I just
talked about like kids nowadays but as
an adult like yeah you should be able to
do it over you play like this like wait
why are we even talking about these
things in terms of kids because this is
an automated game yeah yeah and but if
the game is fun what you're probably
what it might be trash but I might it
looks like are you what if it's kind of
cool and then it's like and then it
makes you like feel bad for killing
that's kind of powerful like cuz it's
like aw please don't kill me and you're
like knife in the eye so that's that's
kind of powerful I don't know it's more
powerful than it was something like
postal 2 which is a game like despise
you every yep I really loved it I
thought it was so funny and this is a
game where you can we're looking this is
postal 3 here add the the these are
games were able to like they're just so
dumb like to everyone thought was super
violin because you could like piss in
people's mouths
there was a button for peeing you could
undo your zip and pee you could set
people on fire with a flamethrower and
then like pee on them to put the mares
yes on the face of it that's cut look at
this guy he's just I don't know ain't
nobody squirting on this don't wanna
know um but it's not like it's a new
thing I mean even looking but like not
just postal but Call of Duty is
something that stands out to me that as
soon as they started putting in those
really violent brutal hand-to-hand kills
like when you go up on a guy and you
just jab a knife into his neck and draw
it across I'm like I I don't like to
watch that in movies I mean I'm not
gonna look away I don't care it's not
bothering me but like I don't seek it
out and I don't want that away a lot of
Animal Crossing and that's my speed yeah
all right first person GTA was another
one where it like stuff looks real nasty
but I feel like that was worse because
that world feels real whereas there's
nothing about hatred that makes me think
this looks like anything other than just
a psychopath fever dream in fact one of
the lines from the developer our site
this is actually from em from Wikipedia
and the player controlled character is a
misanthropic mass killing psychopath who
begins a genocide crusade to kill as
many human beings as possible the
developer described hatred as a reaction
to video game aesthetic trends such as
political correctness politeness vivid
color and games as art so the top three
sound like animal Crossing's you must be
pretty paste yeah whereas that games as
ours like in a weird way he's making
like an artistic statement as games as
being an artistic statement with an
artistic statement like yeah that's what
if that's what they're doing then this
is the most pure form of games as ours
man I mean people are called games art
I'm gonna make a piece of art in the
form of a game yeah to show them yeah
like I don't have to be art it kind of
would be interesting if what you're
saying like if it does make you feel bad
yeah well that's up to that's that's
what's great about games everybody feels
different mm-hmm but I'm all for pushing
the envelope like yeah I grew up in an
area that was super conservative right
and so like I felt like I needed to push
push things and offend people and movies
I made were super violent for like no no
other reason then it was cool for us
it's like that's what we wanted to see I
want to see game like that and I'm maybe
calming down from that
more and more as I get older but like
yeah pilot games there's a place for it
yeah that's the time for it I don't
think that I'm gonna go out and MIT to
everybody but I guess I just did on the
lobby but like am I gonna go like tell
everybody that I meet like hey I love
this game it's the most violent game
I've ever played no probably not but
it's like something I've definitely
check out and be like you it's cool yeah
we haven't gotten to the point yet we're
a violent game can be heralded as
something like wonderful like think of
something that killed Miller for
instance which is like two movies of
really not quite mainstream very easy
okay now the last of us had incredibly
violent scenes and the way that you
murdered and eviscerate if you like but
and it's still critically lauded and
yeah a great game that's a really good
idea actually yeah
about to see it hatred is another one of
those what for what is it a class I'm
not saying it's gonna be the elastance
but it could surprise us we don't know I
guess we'll find out next week it's
available on Steam and it's not
available on GOG it's on the Soraa as
well GOG have decided not to according
to the developer they refused to
distribute the game and but yeah we'll
see hopefully there might be a good game
behind it not just a bunch of press and
fun and marketing yeah we'll know in a
couple days but let us know what you
think in the comments below